okay it's always a bummer when I do this
but I know people like hearing it so I
will do another one of these segments
I've mentioned before that sometimes
people will cancel memberships or pull
patreon funding for reasons that I find
really really depressing and for example
there was one a few months ago where
someone said David I love what you do I
agree with you politically I think
you're providing an extraordinarily
important public service but I am
married with kids and I am NOT going to
support your bachelor lifestyle if you
were married with kids I would
contribute to the program which was a
bummer for me because I would like the
way I decide what to support is on the
merits of what I'm supporting rather
than the circumstances right if I if I
if there's a movie I want to see I could
say I'm not gonna go and support those
wealthy actors they don't need my money
well hold on please if they've made a
movie that I believe is worthwhile then
I will go and pay the eight or as it is
in Boston sixteen or seventeen dollars
to see that film right so that was
really a bummer to me and sadly the New
Year's break that we took led to a huge
influx of further cancellations from
from people some of which I think you'll
find interesting but to me are actually
kind of concerning
a couple people cancelled because they
could tell from my Twitter feed that I
wasn't paying attention to the political
news during the vacation really I'm not
allowed to tune out for just a few days
I need to even during during vacation I
have to pay attention to the political
news that that's not good that's not a
good that's not a way to prevent burnout
yeah you have to refresh and rejuvenate
in 2018 ready to go the other trend from
a couple people was that we are taking
vacation that's the complaint that that
was a complaint right like David I'm
can't I'm pulling my money because a
couple people did this and it's so sad
because you're taking more vacations
than most people in the US get at their
jobs and you're even taking off federal
holidays and really if you're
independent media that's viewer
supported you should really be working
through all that to make as much money
as possible it's so sad because I've
been saying for a decade on the program
we've got a problem with work culture in
the United States I believe more in the
scanned
avian and and European model where it's
really important to take vacation and
what basically this person these people
were saying is I should be a hypocrite I
should go on the show and tell you I
support employers giving staff more
vacation we don't get enough but then I
should try to force my staff to work
through vacations in federal holidays
how does that make any sense and then
provided that we're going to take
vacations from time to time the end of
the year is the time to do it because
very few people are working whenever we
do work through those periods viewership
goes way down because way fewer people
are paying attention to the way families
their friends hanging out it's really
sad and it's disappointing and you know
what the good thing is that most people
in the audience aren't supporting us
with all of these conditions right
they're saying hey I believe in what
you're doing and I trust that you know
when you should do the show and that
you'll do what it makes most sense for
the show with the contributions that we
send but it really was kind of sad and
it always had there's always some
percentage you know but and I said Barry
I you actually wrote back because one
guy was polite in his criticism I said
listen I don't think contributing is
right for you because we're not going to
stop taking the vacations and we're not
gonna stop taking the federal holidays
off I think it's really important but
it's important to prevent burnout it's
important because this is the philosophy
I'm advocating on the show and I would
be a two-faced hypocrite if I said one
thing and then I did the other in terms
of staff time so listen we're doing what
we're doing I think most people are okay
with it and I appreciate the sustaining
members that have been with us for years
and years and years and don't have these
micro expectations of how we're going to
manage everything from vacation time to
to scheduling of holidays yeah we can't
have a few people just take hostage of
how we do things here salute and that's
exactly why you're not considering
getting married and having kids just to
please that one viewer that's exactly
right there was that one viewer who said
if I if I got married and had kids then
his money would flow in not gonna be
bullied that way it's just not gonna
happen